pennsylvania considers welfare reform to
keep food stamps from going to dead
recipients
what a novel idea considers it considers
it because you know we're not sure we're
not sure got it debated got to happen
let's have a debate
should dead people get the the welfare
payments let's have imagine people on
the other side of that debate there'll
be somebody
give it to their give it to their their
youngans i don't know there'll be
somebody to defend that aoc you want to
come on and talk about that maybe she'll
who knows all right this is what it says
awaiting approval
because you know
there's those that may not agree
in the house before it can go to
democratic governor tom wolf for a
signature senate bill 1124 would require
the department of human services to run
a monthly check of death certificates
with the bureau of vital statistics to
ensure that snap benefits
are not spent on deceased individuals so
you might be sitting at home maybe you
run a business and you're saying to
yourself
why weren't they doing this already you
mean to tell me
that they weren't checking
monthly to make sure
that this stuff wasn't going to the dead
already
no they weren't
government efficiency
it's admirable
it's really admirable
this is the best part
this is what they found the impetus for
the bill you might might be wondering
what was it
we found that dhs policy allowed public
assistance benefits to be paid to
recipients up to 12 months after that
people were dead for 12 months still
getting the benefits by the way
that's taxpayer dollars
you live in pennsylvania you're working
every day getting up doing the grind
taxpayer dollars then go
to a dead person for 12 months because
they can't get there but well it's a lot
of work to check those books really
overstuffed bureaucracy how many people
in the government were employed that
were supposed to be doing that that
we're doing what
sitting around doing what exactly you
couldn't get that done
okay
check out the numbers dhs paid out
nearly seven hundred thousand dollars in
benefits to those deceased beneficiaries
seven hundred thousand dollars
i knew you thought i was going to get to
the bottom of the story and it was going
to be like jed's talking about like 10
bucks
700 000 going to dead people
okay
i
can't you may also be saying to yourself
okay
this is pennsylvania
what's going on in the other states
who knows
who knows you think this is just going
to be a problem that oh we caught this
and it's going on in pennsylvania hell
no
of course not that just means that
pennsylvania did a little digging
i don't know why they did a little
digging a little extra and they found
this of course this is happening in
other states this is waste
this is your money
your money
that they can't be bothered to spend
well that's when people say i love
people say oh
spending
spending is the answer government
spending government's responsible
[ __ ]
i know chris said i didn't say [ __ ]
on the show yet so i had a remedy that
today
and i said it had to be organic and it
was
[ __ ]
the government does not spend your money
efficiently you are more likely to spend
your money efficiently because you earn
it
not saying everybody's going to be smart
about cash but you're going to be
smarter than
you're going to send your money out to
some dead people that you don't know
this is ridiculous
don't get me aggravated with this
nonsense government effect trust the
government and when people say that it's
efficient
yeah take a walk around you ever go to
the dmv government things that are run
by the government you're oh you leave
there yeah the va right you leave
exhausted you feel like you've been
through some terrible war when you
encounter something that's being run by
the government you leave you're like
you've lost layers of your life you've
got gray hairs you didn't have before
you feel broke you feel like you feel
like everything's gone wrong that day
okay
come on less government
not more please if you like the short
clip you can catch another one here or
you can catch the full episode right
here
[Music]